[Música]
y va a suspender un punto por donde
transita casi un tercio del gas que
rusia envía al resto de europa porque
estaba ubicado en una de las provincias
controladas por moscú la compañía rusa
gazprom alega que el nuevo lugar elegido
no tiene la capacidad para transportar
tanto suministro les explicamos en
minutos
la inteligencia de eeuu sostiene que el
presidente ruso vladimir putin quiere
extender su poder más allá del bombas
según el organismo los militares de
moscú pretenden controlar todas las
zonas que conectan hasta moldavia
tendremos un reporte desde ucrania
casi 500 mil dólares ofrece la policía
colombiana aquí en la información del
sospechoso de haber asesinado al fiscal
paraguayo marcelo pecci a este
funcionario que investigado a casos de
narcotráfico en su país le dispararon en
la isla colombiana de barú durante su
luna de miel
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
gusto estar con ustedes
y comenzamos con las novedades de la
guerra el sistema operador de gas en
ucrania anunció que quiere suspender un
punto por donde transita casi un tercio
del combustible que rusia envía al resto
de europa
el administrador ucraniano alega y lo
citó un motivo de fuerza mayor para
frenar el gas que pasa por el punto
fronterizo de su kranjska en la región
de lugansk que ya está bajo el control
de los rusos las autoridades ucranianas
quieren transferir temporalmente la
capacidad al punto de schütz a que es
más al occidente y está controlado por
ellos quieren garantizar que el gas
llegue a europa pero gazprom alega que
es técnicamente imposible pasar tanto
volumen por allí nos acompaña en estudio
nuestro periodista especializado en
economía jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido
y cuéntenos un poco más de esta decisión
maria clara por esa estación pasaban
hasta ahora 32 6 millones de metros
cúbicos de gas al día esto es un tercio
del total que ucrania transportaba hasta
europa rusia ha estado enviando gas a
través de ucrania con normalidad pese a
la guerra pero quien había advertido que
el flujo podría interrumpirse un
portavoz de gazprom la estatal rusa
confirmó que fueron notificados por
ucrania de la interrupción pendiente
como mencionabas la opción que dio la
empresa ucraniana para no afectar el
volumen previsto hacia europa es recibir
el gas por un punto medio ya conocido
como xuxa que está por supuesto un poco
más al norte de este punto que fue
interrumpido por esa estación pasan unos
77 millones de metros cúbicos de gas y
se encuentra en territorio controlado
por ucrania pero gazprom rechazó esa
posibilidad como bien mencionaba el 27%
de los flujos pasaban por su cronista y
el resto por sutsha se espera que los
envíos de gas disminuyan un 18% respecto
al día anterior es probable que esta
reducción haga subir el precio del gas a
europa tras las ganancias del 5,4 por
ciento al cierre del mercado rusia
suministra alrededor del 40 por ciento
de la demanda de gas en la unión europea
aproximadamente un tercio de ellas envía
como mencionamos a través de ucrania lo
que convierte a ucrania
la clave para la seguridad energética
del 'viejo continente'
jorge gracias por este reporte y en
otras noticias de la guerra en ucrania
la inteligencia nacional de eeuu afirma
que el presidente ruso vladimir putin se
estaría preparando para un conflicto
prolongado la directora del organismo
avión heinz sostuvo antes del senado que
moscú quiere controlar más allá de la
región separatista del donbass para
ganar territorio a lo largo de la costa
del mar negro y llegar a moldavia una de
esas zonas es la ciudad portuaria de
odessa que fue bombardeada el martes los
ataques dejaron al menos una persona
muerta ucrania afirma que moscú quiere
cortar las líneas de suministro
la ruta que conduce hacia el easy dance
en el este de ucrania es estratégica en
la batalla por la provincia de lugar que
si esta vía cae varias poblaciones que
se encuentran en medio del fuego cruzado
quedarán aisladas nuestros enviados
especiales catalina gómez ángel y mikel
konaté llegaron hasta allí y esto fue lo
que vieron
esta carretera es el nuevo gran objetivo
de las fuerzas rusas que buscan cortar
el acceso a la provincia de lugares en
el este del país
de lograr su objetivo
ciudades como lis y chance quedarán
aisladas y muy cerca de quedar bajo el
control del gobierno de moscú
el cruce de fuego y los bombardeos hacen
que huir sea una misión marcada por el
peligro
este es el caso de natacha alexander y
hiena que esperan la llegada de buses
humanitarios para ser evacuados
la noche fue el límite
atacaron este lugar ayer nuestras casas
fueron destruidas perdimos todo
da mucho miedo
empezaron a bombardear no es tan duro
imagínense un proyectil volando por
encima de mi cabeza y explotar en frente
de mí es un milagro que logramos escapar
de ese lugar después de horas de espera
han entendido que los ataques impiden
que los vehículos lleguen a su rescate
antonina aprovecha que los ataques han
mermado y ha salido a dar un paseo
tenemos muchos problemas con el agua
potable vamos al pozo y la sacamos de
allí
cada uno tiene sus razones para quedarse
a pesar de los peligros como misiles
como este que ha quedado sin explotar
en esta área se libró una de las
batallas más duras por el dominio del
este del país la ciudad ha quedado
atrapada en el cruce de fuego de las
fuerzas rusas ucranianas que la
defienden desde los alrededores
la vida para las pocas personas que se
han quedado indecisión es un básicamente
un infierno hay bombardeos hay
artillería que cae en las calles están
completamente solas nos dicen que no hay
agua tampoco hay electricidad no hay
conexión a internet no hay líneas
telefónicas y ellos nos dicen que
solamente cuando bajan un poco los
ataques salen a la calle compran su
comida y vuelven a sus casas a los
refugios subterráneos
la situación económica también impide
que muchos tomen la decisión de
marcharse como ara que venden las
verduras y huevos que producen su jardín
horrible la situación es horrible
bombardean todos los días incluso lo
hicieron el 9 de mayo ferrán el futuro
de la ciudad y los habitantes que
permanecen depende de la lucha que se
libra en esta carretera donde hasta
bailar bandera ucraniana sigue ondeando
de ucrania pasados al continente
americano la policía de colombia está
ofreciendo una recompensa de 490 mil
dólares estadounidenses a quien dé
información sobre quién le habría
disparado al fiscal paraguayo marcelo
pecci este funcionario trabajaba contra
el crimen organizado el narcotráfico el
lavado de dinero y el financiamiento del
terrorismo en paraguay le dispararon el
martes en la isla de barú cerca de
cartagena donde celebraba a su luna de
miel autoridades paraguayas y de eeuu se
sumaron a la investigación melissa
chávez nos cuenta
el fiscal marcelo pecci fue asesinado en
la isla colombiana de barú cercana a la
turística ciudad de cartagena de indias
estaba encargado de investigar casos de
narcotráfico lavado de dinero y crimen
organizado en su país seguirá en la
lucha contra el crimen organizado una
lástima esto es muy doloroso muy duro he
conversado con el presidente iván duque
por teléfono
se ha comprometido conmigo para darnos
todo nuestro apoyo para resolver el caso
para buscar a los responsables
también he conversado con el gobierno
americano con respecto a eso quienes
también a través de colombia van a
apoyar casos como el del futbolista
brasileño ronaldinho quien en 2020
intentó entrar en paraguay con un
pasaporte falso el del asesinato de la
hija de un gobernador regional le dieron
reconocimiento a nivel nacional e
internacional al fiscal de 45 años que
además investigaba el asesinato de dos
personas durante un festival paraguayo
mientras tocaba un grupo musical
colombiano conocido como el binomio de
oro ya tenemos informaciones que están
siendo recolectadas en los actos
urgentes y que son de carácter reservado
que nos ayudarán a identificar a los
responsables de este lamentable hecho
una delegación de la policía paraguaya
formará parte del equipo de
investigación en colombia en el que
también participarán funcionarios de
eeuu
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador no está dispuesto a ir a
la cumbre de las américas que se
celebrará en junio en los ángeles esto
si eeuu no invita a todos los países de
la región aunque aclaró que sí enviaría
a su canciller marcelo ebrad el
pronunciamiento llega luego de que la
casa blanca afirmara que era poco
probable que convocará a gobiernos como
el de cuba venezuela o nicaragua lo que
lópez obrador rechazó diciendo que en
otros momentos para confrontaciones sino
para la unión
en haití al menos 148 personas han sido
asesinadas desde el 24 de abril cuando
empezó la guerra de dos bandas armadas
en la capital puerto príncipe el dato es
de la ong red nacional de defensa de
derechos humanos de haití y duplica los
75 fallecidos de los que habla la onu
entre las víctimas registradas por la
organización haitiana figuran siete
integrantes de la banda quien merchán
que fueron ejecutados por el mismo jefe
de la pandilla el informe describe
además masacres algunas cometidas por el
grupo 400 magos
hasta aquí las noticias los invitamos a
que sigan con france24
[Música]